اهلا بكم مشاهدينا ونواصل تغطيتنا
للاشتباكات العنيفه في السودان وحرب
البيانات المستمره بين الجنرانين البرهان
وحميتي حيث لا افق واضح لنهايتها حتى الان
قبل قيام مشاهدينا قال الجيش المصري ان
قال ان ثلاثه طائرات عسكريه قامت باخلاء
قواتنا من السودان واكد المتحدث العسكري
باسم القوات المسلحه المصريه استمرار
التعاون والتنسيق مع الاجهزه الامنيه في
السودان لتامين عوده القوات المسيه الى
بلادهم ولفت الى اتخاذ كافه اجراءات
التنسيق لهبوط ثلاث طائرات نقل عسكريه في
احد مطارات السودان من جانبها ثمنه
الخارجيه المصريه نجاح جهود تامين سلامه
بقيه الجنود المصريين في السودان مؤكده ان
مصر والامارات داعمتان لوقف التصعيد في
السودان والعوده للمساري السياسي ايضا
[موسيقى]
حملها رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان قوات الدعم السريعه
المسؤوليه الكامله عن اعمال نهب في
الخرطوم ودارفور البرهان اكد في تصريحات
لصحيفه
ان جزءا كبيرا من قوات الدعم السريع خرجت
عن السيطره وبين رئيس مجلس السياده ان
الانتقال الى المسار الديمقراطي في
السودان مرهون بهزيمه قوات حماتي وفقا
للصحيفه من جهته وفي تصريحات تايمز ايضا
اكد قائد قوه
الملقب بحميتي اكد ان قوته لن تتراجى عن
اهدافها
اوضح ان قوات الدعم السريع منفتحه على وقف
اعمال العنف لكن البرهان لن يتوقف وليس
مستعدا للانتقال للحكم المدني
افاد الصحيفه نقلا عن مصادر مطلعه بان
الاداره الامريكيه تستعد لفرض عقوبات على
طرفي النزاع في السودان وتشير المصادر الى
ان العقوبات التي لم ينجز اعدادها بعد
ستطالب مسؤولين في القوات المسلحه
السودانيه وقوات الدعم السريع على حد سواء
وفي الوقت ذاته اعرب مسؤولون امريكيون عن
مخاوفهم من ان العقوبات لن تكون كافيه
وتاتي متاخره وتعليق على الموضوع قال
متحدث باسم الخارجي الامريكيه ان اداره بل
قال ان اداره الرئيس جو بايدن بشكل عام لا
تعلنوا مسبقا عن العقوبات المحتمله لكنها
تدرس جميع الخيارات المتاحه مع شركائها
لضمان رد منسق ومناسب حيثما كان ممكنا حسب
قوله
ايضا مشاهدينا اعلن الجيش السوداني في
بيان الله جلاء وسبعه وسبعين جنديا مصريا
كان محتجا في مروي من قبل دعم السريع
واضاف البيان ان عمليات الاجلاء تمت عبر
اربع طائرات عسكريه مصريه من مطار
واوضح ان وجود الاطقم الفنيه المصريه في
السودان كان بموجب بروتوكول تدريب مشترك
وحول الانباء المتداوله عن تدخل الليبي في
الصراع نفت القوات المسلحه الليبيه بقياده
خليفه حفتر نفد تقديم الدعم لطرف ضد الاخر
من طرفي الصراع الدائري في السودان واوضح
المتحدث باسم الجيش الوطني الليبي احمد
المسماري ان القوات المسلحه الليبيه تقوم
حاليا باجراء الاتصالات العاجله مع
الاطراف المعنيه مضيفا ان القياده مستعده
للقيام بدور الوساطه
مشاهدينا من القاهره ينضم الينا الكاتب
الصحفي احمد الخطيب اهلا استاذ احمد معنا
في هذه التغطيه بدايه اسمع تعليقها على
على ازمه الجنود المصريين وهل بوصولهم الى
القاهره سالمين يمكن القول ان الازمه قد
انتهت تماما
لا توجد ازمه بين القاهره والخرطوم حتى
الان
بخصوص الجنود المصريين
الامر انتهى الى السلامه الكامله بوصول
الجنود القاهره معنيه بالدرجه الاولى
بالامن القومي العربي في السودان الامر
القوم العربي وما يحدث السودان وبلا شك
القاهره هي اول الموجوعين به دون غيرها
لان نص تعتبر السودان جزء منها والسودان
يعتبر القاهره مصر جزء منهم وهو اي شيء
يحدث في السودان هو بالضروره ينعكس سلبا
على على البلاد في مصر وكذلك في السودان
المصري تريد للسودان ان تعود الى طاوله
المفاوضات ان يعود الفرقاء هناك انجاز
التعبير الى طاوله المفاوضات وانت ان يعود
الى حل السياسي على الطاوله ليس الحل
العسكريه الحل العسكري يقود اي اي حل
عسكري في اي مكان في العالم يقول الى
الدمار والتخريب وما لا يحمد عقباه
السودان دوله كبيره عدد سكان كبير
متراميه الاطراف دوله مهمه جدا جدا في
الاقليم تمثل امن قومي حقيقي للوطن العربي
كله وليس بمصر فقط ومن ثم على على الفرقاء
في السودان ان يجلسوا في اقرب وقت على
طاوله المفاوضات وان ينهوا هذه المساله
لان الحروب الاهليه والتقاسمات الاهليه هي
اخطر ما يكون واخطر ما يمس اي بلد في اي
مكان في الدنيا طيب يعني ماذا بعد ايضا
يعني هل من تد اعيات يمكن ان تفرضها هذه
الحادثه التي حدثت الجنود المصريين على
موقف مصر ما يحدث في السودان هل على موقعه
على موقفها من الدعم السريع تحديدا خاصه
وان هناك مقاطع فيديو انتشرت تظهر
اعتداءات على هؤلاء الجنود من قبل الجنود
في الدعم السريع او عناصر في الدعم
السريعه
القاهره القاهره الان تنظر
للازمه بالجمله وليست مساله الجذور
المصريين هي يعني عاد الجنود بسلام
القاهره لديها خطوط تواصل جيد مع الجميع
في كل مكان لاسيما
اوضحت ان وجود الجنود المصريين في
لم يكونوا ولن يكونوا طرف اي صراع لان
القاهره لديها مبدا مهم جدا وهو
في كل دوله
سياسيه او غير سياسيه يعني مصر رؤيه واضحه
وشامله منذ سنوات طويله وان شئت
مصر ترى هذا لا تدخل في شؤون اي دوله وتقف
على مسافه واحده تتمنى الامن
والسلام لا تتدخل
لدى الجيران وتقف معهم
اي نزاع او اي مشكله تقرا على الامن
القومي العربي بالجمله طيب السؤال الاخير
استاذ احمد يعني يومين واقع ملك الصحفي
يعني هل توفرت لك معلومات حول الوضع الصحي
لهؤلاء الجنود بعد وصولهم الى القاهره
يعني الامور كلها بيد الجيش المصري هو
لديه متحدث المتحدث
يكاشف الراي العام
بكل الاحداث بالامس يعني المصريون او كيف
عاد الجنود المصريون على المتحدث المصري
المتحدث للجيش المصري ونشر صورا بعوده
الجنود سالمين امنين وصممته الخارجيه هذه
الخطوه مع الخرطوم الامور تسير جيدا لكن
كل ما يهم القاهره هو امن وسلامه السودان
لان
ما يحدث في السودان يعني يزعج كل مخزي وكل
وكل عربي لان السودان دوله عزيزه على
الجميع وعلى السودانيين كما قلت عنفا عن
يجلس يعودوا الى طاوله
المفاوضات وان يستبعدوا الخيار العسكري
والحروب لان الحروب لا تؤدي الى شيء
شكرا لكم من القاهره كنت معنا الكاتبه
الصحفي احمد الخطيب
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرت لها طالما ان
الجنراللين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها
الشخصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لحق بالركب ولم يفوته القطار دوله
شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه والعسكريه
كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا ولبنان حيث
يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع بالسياده وحق
تقرير المصير اي دول ديوري وفق القانون
الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على الجانب الاخر
من القائمه دول مسلوبه القرار ومهمشه بحكم
الواقع او دفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه
السودان يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي
يربط اهم ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب
وقناه السويس ما يزيد مغريات الدوله
الذهبيه الكثيره في عيون دول كبرى بينها
روسيا وتركيا فحلم القاعده البحريه هناك
تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرلين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
ثم استلام
عسكر
استلام عدد
واحد
[موسيقى]
من فضله في هذه الساعه
وتم الاستدلاع على عدد خمسه عربه كروزر
حريق في مهند للسلاح مهند للسلاح حريق في
الخرطوم اثنين شارع الصناعات شارع
الصناعات في العمارات اللي قاعده فوق وما
قادر تطلع شو اسر قاعده فوق ما قادر تطلع
حريق حريق
حريق من محل بتاع الذخيره
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه اني ده الصغاثه لاي زول بيعرف اي
جهه مطافي في اي جهه ممكن تجي تتدخل في
الحته دي الناس المفروض تجي في الحته دي
فوق
اطفال قاعدين فوق في العماره والناس اللي
ما قدرت تطلع
وفي ثلاثه ولا اكثر من اربع عمارات موجوده
تحت لبعض وهادي الناس حسك على التجري
نداء استغاثه يا جماعه في اكتر من اربع
عمارات جنب بعض يفوز قاعده فوق ما قادر
تنزل
مشاهدينا من الخرطوم ينضمون لان سيدي احمد
الكاتب الصحفي هذه التغطيه وبدايه هل يمكن
القول ان السودان اليوم لن يعود مثل
السودان الامس وما يحدث الان سيفرض واقعا
جديدا على هذا البلد واذا كان الواقع كذلك
يعني كيف ستكون ملامح هذا الواقع في
تقديرك
نتمنى ونحن على يعني كما يقول اهلنا في
السودان قبائل العيد
نتمنى ان ياتي العيد غدا وقد توقف هذا
الصوت الفظيع وهذا الصوت المجنون الذي لا
ناقه للشعب السودان فيه ولا جمل
نحن لازم نامل
ونتوقع ان يتوقف القتال وان تعود الاطراف
الى معده التفاوض انا اعتقد انه لا زالت
هناك فرصه
لوقف اطلاق النار ولا زالت هناك فرصه
لتطويق هذا القتال في في الحته التي يقف
فيها الان الامور اعتقد انها تحت السيطره
لا زال بامكان قائد الجيش ان يدير المعركه
في الشكل بشكل يتجه الى الى وقفها
انه كذلك الدعم السريع بامكانه ان يصدر
تعليمات بعناصره
بوقف القتال انا لا اعتقد ان المثل خرجت
على السيطره
ولكن من المهم جدا ان نشير كذلك الى الى
ان القتال في المناطق التي نقتنها نحن وهي
منطقه الخرطوم جنوب يكاد
يكون لا يوجد قتال لا نسمع صوت رصاص او
دليل انفجارات اللهم الا من الناحيه
الشماليه التي تقع فيها قياده القوات
المسلحه ولكن المناطق التي كانت تدور فيها
معارك وهي مناطق مهمه جدا مثل سلاح
المدرعات ومسك الوحده التي كانت تتبع
لقوات الدعم السريع والمجاوره للمدرعات
ومنطقه سوبا وكل هذه المناطق من الواضح ان
القوات المسلحه يعني استطاعت ان تسيطر
عليها واستطاعت ان تخرج قوات الدعم السريع
من هذه المناطق طيب ولكن ايضا فيما يتعلق
بجزئيه امكانيه انهاء هذا الصراع بشكل
سلمي او باقل الخسائر كما يقال اسد عادل
يعني بالنظر الى تصريحات الرجلين الحرب
الاعلام بينهما انتقلت الى ساحات خارجيه
بحديثهما
مثلا حماتي يقول ان المسار الديمقراطي في
السودان مرهم او عفوا هو البرهان يقولون
المسار الديمقراطي في السودان مرهم قوات
حمايه يعني تصريحات اللاذعه من حمايه
حينما يقول ان البرحان ليس مستعدا
للانتقال الحكمه المدني وغير ذلك يعني هل
يشهد ذلك بان حل هذه الازمه او نظره لها
يمكن ان يتم بين الرجلين من غير الاعتماد
مستقبلا على المقاربه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
الموقف العسكري على الموقف الاعلامي انا
اعتقد انه الاعلام هو نوع من الحرب
النفسيه بين الطرفين لا يمكن التعليل
عليها في الموقف على الارض ولكن بصوره
عامه وبصوره فنيه تحت انا اعتقد انه الجيش
بما يملك من امكانيات بما يملك من عراقه
وتجربه في مواجهه انواع كثيره جدا من
المواجهه العسكريه في التاريخ السياسي
السوداني انا اعتقد انه ميزان القوه لصالح
الجيش
وكفت
الموقف على
القوات المسلحه السودانيه هذا الكلام نقول
من ناحيه الفنيه بحسب المشاهدات وبحسب ما
يتوفر لنا معلومات وبحسب تاريخ الجيش
السوداني في التعامل مع المواجهات
العسكريه في احداث عده حدثت في تاريخ
السودان السياسي القريب ولكن في العدل
هناك ايضا يعني قد يقول قائل ان قوه الدعم
ما زالت صامله حتى اللحظه رغم هذه الضربات
الموجه عليه الجيش هل يعود ذلك في تقديرك
الى حاله من التوازن القوى ربما فرضها عدم
قدره احدهما على الحسم حتى الان واتحدث عن
الجيش تحديدا الذي لم يحسم هذه المعارك
حتى اللحظه
لا يوجد توازن هو كما قلت لك وهذه قبل
قليل
الامريكيه حينما قال ان هناك تفوق المسلحه
في سلاح الجو وفي سلاح المدفعيه واضف الى
ذلك سلاح المدرعات انا اعتقد ان هذه حقيقه
فنيه بحث لا لا جدال حولها اما فيما يتعلق
المساله الصمود والدعم السريع انا اعتقد
انه الصمود
سببه الاساسي تواجد هذه القوات في مناطق
حيويه يعني قلب الخرطوم يغضون كميه من
الوزارات وكميه من المؤسسات والمنكر
المركزي وكميه من البنوك كلها مواقع حيويه
ومواقع مهمه جدا مما تتطلب مما تطلب من
الجيش ان يتعامل معها بطريقه تختلف عن
العمليات التي كانت دائره في مروي مثلا او
كانت دائره او ظلت دائره في غرب ام درمان
او حتى في منطقه سوبا هذه المناطق فيها
مساحات مكشوفه تمكن السلاح الجو وسلاح
المشاه والمدفعيه من الدخول في معركه
قصائد كبيره ولكن في قلب الخرطومه الوضع
يختلف مما يتطلب عمليه جراحيه دقيقه
ويكون فيها حرف عالي على التصوير دون ان
تتسبب القوات المسلحه في احداث خسائر
كبيره في هذه المناظر هذا ما
يفسر عمليات في قلب
بشكل بطيء كما يحدث في مناطق الاخرى طيب
تداعيات هذه المعارك على المديين المتوسط
والبعيد يعني هل يمكن حصرها في المكاسب
السياسيه التي ربما تتحقق لطرفين ام ان
هناك في تقديرك ضروره دعنا نقول للقلق من
تداعيات اخرى نتحدث عن الاستقطاب العرقيه
والاثني في السودان نتحدث عن انخراط حركات
مسلحه اخرى في هذا الصراع او ربما
انشقاقات قد تطالوا هذا الطرف او ذاك
[موسيقى]
وربما حتى تكوين الدعم السريع بقدر كبير
جدا تكوين القوات المسلحه لم يقم اصلا على
اي نواحي اسميه او قبليه بل ظلت القوات
المسلحه هي عبر تاريخها طويل انا اتحدث من
ناحيه فنيه بحته دون ما اكون هذا لهذا
الطرف اوجدك اقول ان القوات المسلحه
السودانيه منذ ان انشات عام 1925 وتمت
سودانات عام 1955
يعني بحث ولعلك من خلال الصور التي تاتي
اليكم
والمنتشره في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
وغيره ما يشير الى ان العناصر القوات
المسلحه يمثلون كل اهل السودان غربه وشرقه
وشماله ووصفه وما الى ذلك مما يشير بجلاء
الى ان
البوتقه هذه هي صمام امان
لا ينزلق السودان نحو اي مواجهات
المسلحات تم تشكيله على اساس قومي طيب
ماذا عن الدعم السريع
يعني الى حد ما على الرغم منه الدعم
السريع نشا
بطريقه يعني فيها بدايات تدل على العمق
القبلي
ولكن في خاتمه المطاف بما
بالجيش من احتضان لهذه القوه في فتره من
الفترات ووضع قيادات من القوات المسلحه
وبعض الاجهزه الاخرى الاجهزه الامنيه
الاخرى
ده اعطى الدعم السريع ملمح من ملامح وجود
عناصر على اساس قومي ولكن
في طويله الدعم السريع الذي تم في العهد
الباي قام على اساس معين فيه بعدان البعد
الاول هو
مولد زكريا في اقليم محدث وفي ظروف محدده
وهي ظروف حرب دارفور المساله الاخرى
الزعيم او غائضا نظام المخلوع عمر البشير
نهايه النظام وحمايه نفسه وحمايه حزب هذه
الظروف غير الطبيعيه هي التي اتت للدعم
السريع ولكن بعد الثوره حدثت اشياء جديده
وحدث التطورات مختلفه
لم تنتهي من حقيقه تكوين الدعم السريع
وكانت هناك محاولات جاده ومحاولات مضنيه
عبر
الاتفاق الايطالي ومناقشات قاعه الصداقه
وغيره باشراف الاليه الدوليه ان يتم دمج
قوات الدعم السريع اليك مره اخرى عادل
فيما يتعلق بتكوين الدعم السريع لكن
اسمحلي ان اشير الى هذه الاخبار العاجله
نقل عن رسائل العربيه نتحدث عن اشتباكات
في اندرمان وتحليق للطيران الحربي ايضا في
سماء الخرطوم هذا عدا عن الحديث قبل قيل
عن اصوات مدفعيه تدور يدور صباحها في ام
درمان نشاهد ايضا متابعينا هذه الصور
المباشره والخاصه بالعربيه من عمق الخطوط
حيث تتصاعد اعمده الدخان جديد في هذا
الموقع القريب نسبيا من القياده العامه او
محيط القياده العامه السودانيه هذا في ظل
الاشتباكات الدائره لليوم السادس على
التوالي ومنذ هذا الصباح مشاهدينا فقد دوت
اصوات القذائف وتبادل اطلاق النار واقع
قاعه الرصاص في خمس مناطق من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم نتحدث عن مقر الجيش
والقصر الجمهوري ومبنى التلفزيون وسلاح
المهندسين وذلك مشاهدينا
رغم هدنه معلنه لم تصمت امام ذوي الرصاص
وتبادل الاتهامات بخرقها وتحضيرات ايضا
مشاهدينا
امميه من وضع كارثي
لتفاقم الازمه الانسانيه استاذ عادل يعود
اليك من جديد يعني وفي متعلق ايضا بتكوين
الدعم السريع وانت الصحافي روما لديك
معلومات حول هذا الموضوع هل صحيح ما يتردد
عن ان قوه تدعم ايضا بمكوناتها عناصر
اجنبيه ولا ليست سودانيه تماما اتحدث عن
عناصر من دول افريقيه قد شاهد النيجر وغير
ذلك على العكس تماما يعني كل العناصر فيها
هي عناصر سودانيه
طبعا اصلا في افريقيا حينما تقوم اي قوه
عسكريه خارج
رحم القوات المسلحه تكون عرضه لدخول عناصر
اجنبيه فيها لذلك انا اعتقد انه في مرحله
ما لا استبعد ان تكون قوات الدعم السريع
بتضمت عناصر من دول الجوار الافريقي
والسوداني يجاور دول افريقيه كثيره في
متاخمه لمنطقه دارفور وما الى ذلك
ولا
املك دارفور يعني كانت قوات الدعم السريع
قوات كما قلت لك بدات
قانون وبدات كقوات اهليه لذلك في ذلك
الوضع في تلك الظروف من الممكن ان تكون قد
استوعبت عناصر من جهات من جهات مختلف او
من جهه مختلف
ما مدى المسؤوليه التي يتحملها الرئيس
المخلوع السابق عمر البشير ونظامه فيما
تمر به الخرطوم الان والسودان اجمع ايضا
السابق نظام المخلوع عمر بشير هو الذي
اورث السودان كل هذه المشاكل على المستوى
الاقتصادي بسبب سياسات ورعناء الذي افضت
الى مقاطعه دوليه للسودان وحصار
سياسه العسكريه التي قامت على انشاء
قوات خاصه سواء كان في جهاز الامن
والمخابرات او الدعم السريع او محاولاته
الكثيره التي كان يهدف من ورائها الى
انشاء قوه مسلحه موازيه لانه كان يخشى
كثيرا جدا من القوات المسلحه السودانيه
والجيش انا اعتقد انه
ما وجدناه السابق يعني ورث مثقله بالهموم
وبالمشاكل
وبالبلاوي كما يقول اهلنا ولقد كان
عمر البشير ولكن من المفارقات العجيبه
وربما هي حسابات الاهيه ان الدعم الشرير
حينما قامت ثوره الشعب السوداني العظيمه
وثوره الشباب الجباره اضطر الدعم السريع
ان ينحاز الى الشارع السوداني في تلك
الثوره ولكن عموما اقول لك ان عمر البشير
سيسال امام الله عن الجرائم التي ارتكبها
عن المصائب التي تركها بعد سقوط نظامي طيب
وفيما يتعلق بما وصفته بالمسمار يعني في
في جسد السودان يعني هل على السودان ان
يتعايش مع هذا المسمار ام انه في مرحله ما
قد يتمكن من خلعه تماما
بالطبع كان السودانيون عبر حوارات من
المتعدده سواء كان في منبر الاتفاق
الايطالي او اي مابر اخرى كان هناك
راي سياسي قاطع ومتفق عليه بين القوه
السياسيه والقوات المسلحه السودانيه وحتى
تعمل السريع على خلع هذا المسمار بطرق
سياسيه لذلك الاتفاق الايطالي كان يناقش
هذا الملف والملف
والعسكري
بروحه وطنيه عاليه جدا كانت تسير في اتجاه
كيفيه انهاء وجود الدعم السريع في شارع
السوداني وتحقيق هذا المطلب الملح الذي
كان يصر عليه الثوار
في
المليون يجب ان يتم حل الدعم طيب السيد
عادل السيد احمد كاتب الصحفي تفضل بالبقاء
هذه التغطيه
ومشاهدينا في تطورات المعارك في السودان
اتهمت قوات الدعم السريعه الجيش السوداني
بمهاجمه قواتها في ام درمان مشيره الى
تمكن قوتها من التصدي الهجوم على
تمركزاتها غرب المدينه واضافت القوات التي
تتبع حميدتي ان عناصرها اسقطت مروحيتين
للقوات الجويه السودانيه خلال عمليه
التصدي كما اكدت علامه وصفته بالتزام
قواتها بالبقاء في مواقعها ووقف اطلاق
النار منذ اعلان الهدنه
[موسيقى]
محاور عده للنزاع في السودان من ابرزها ما
يدور في العاصمه لكن الاعين تتوجه ايضا
لمنطقه اخرى الى اكبر ولايات السودان
الولايه الشماليه التي برز من بين مدنها
بشكل لافت مروي الواقعه على بعد 350
كيلومترا شمال العاصمه الخرطوم المدينه
ذات اهميه عسكريه كبيره ازدادت مع الصراع
الحالي بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع جل
التركيز صب على مطار المدينه للجانبين
المدني والعسكري وتضاربت الانباء حول
الجانب المسيطر عليه الى ان اعلن الجيش عن
اعاده السيطره على مطار مروي المطار يعتبر
قاعده جويه مسانده ومنطقه تمركز بديله
للقواعد العسكريه الاخرى في السودان ويغطي
مطارها العمليات الجويه في شمال السودان
وشرقه وغربه اهميه مطار مروي تتاتى من
كونه احد اكبر المطارات في افريقيا فهو
يقع على مساحه 18 كيلوم وهو مصمم لاستيعاب
هبوط واقلاع الطائرات الضخمه بمهبط طائرات
بطول حوالي اربعه كيلو مترات وعرض 60 مترا
وفي مطار مروي ومحيطه تنتشر قوات الفرقه
تسعه عشر التابعه للجيش السوداني المسؤوله
عن حمايه المرافق الاستراتيجيه في المنطقه
ان شاء الله
هذا عامر
فوق فانها فوق
[موسيقى]
حتى لوزير التحيه فنحن مسلمين
اللواء الاول
مشاهده اللغات البريه السند للغات البريه
65 دبابه الان كلها محروقه الان وهي
بالعمل
القياده العامه
لحد الان
بينعمل 65 دبابه اللي هي
المسانده للقياده العامه
اللي هو الاول
البريه 65 دبابه العمل لحد الان نار مولعه
[موسيقى]
وحول تداعيات الصحيه والمعيشيه الصعبه
التي يعيشها السودانيون في هذه الظروف حذر
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي من ان القتال في
السودان يهدد الملايين بمجاعه وفي
تصريحاته العربيه ناشد المدير الاقليمي
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه احمد المنظر ناشد
الاطراف السودانيه التزام بالقوائم
الدوليه مشيرا الى ان ما يحدث في السودان
اكبر من قدره الهيئات الصحيه واكد المتحدث
باسم وزاره الصحه السودانيه الدكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن في لقاء مع العربيه
اكد ان خروج بعض المستشفيات عن الخدمه في
الخرطوم لم يشكل عبئا على سير النظام
الصحي وقال المتحدث باسم الوزاره ان
المستشفيات التي خرجت عن الخدمه كانت بسبب
وقوعها في مرمى النيران وتم تفريغها
لمستشفيات بديله امنه
الاطراف المتنازعه الالتزام
بقانون الدولي المختص بهذا الموضوع وحمايه
ارواح المدنيين خلال هذه النزاعات لكن
للاسف كما هو معروف لا يغلب يعني صوت
العقل خلال هذه المحن والازمات وانما يغلب
صوت السلاح للاسف فنناشد كذلك يعني الجميع
داخل السودان ان يلتزموا بالاخذ الحيطه
والحذر وعدم الخروج الى الاماكن الخطره
حتى يضمنوا كذلك يعني التزام الاطراف
المتنازعه بالهده وبالتالي عدم تعرض
تعرضهم للمخاطر وفقدان الارواح الكثيره
المسلسلات التي خرجت من الخدمه عشر
مستشفيات عامه في القطاع العام و20 مستشفى
القطاع الخاص عدد المستشفيات التي خرجت لا
تشكل عبئا على على سير النظام الصحي لانه
عدد الاسر الموجود عندنا هو انا مستغل 30%
من مغذره المسلسلات على تقديم الخدمات
الصحيه التردد الان في ظل تقديم الخدمه
يساوي اثنين من 10% من التردد الطبيعي في
الاوقات الطبيعيه وبالتالي
وبالتالي خروج المستشفيات عدد من
المستشفيات لان في مرمى النار لان
المسيفات غير امنه وتم تفريغها لمستشفيات
امنه بديله هذا لا لا ينذر بانهيار النظام
الصحي كما يقولون يعني
مشاهدينا ينضموا اخرتهم بحري اذا ينضموا
الينا الصحفي عمار بوشيبه اهلا بك سيد
عمار معنا في هذه
النشره في هذه التغطيه بدايه ما الذي يمكن
ان تقوله لنا عن مشاهداتك ومعيشته اليوم
وفي الايام السابقه على ضوء ما تمر به
الخرطوم من اوضاع استثنائيه وغير مسبوقه
اهلا بك يا احمد واهلا بالمشاهدين الكرام
يعني في صبيحه هذا اليوم في مدينه بحري
كان هنالك التحليق كثيف للطيران الحربي
وطلعات جويه بعدها تصدد المضادات الارضيه
التي كانت او في الاماكن التي يتحصن بها
تتحصن بها قوه الدعم السريع داخل مدينه
بحري الان
الاوضاع في المدينه هنالك طلعات لعدد من
الطائرات الحربيه وهنالك تصدي واشتباك
يبدو بانه في عدد من المناطق خاصه
المتاخمه لسوق الكبير باتجاه جسر
وايضا في منطقه كافوري في المنطقه الشرقيه
من المدينه نسمع الان عدد من الاصوات
للاعير الناريه والمضادات الارضيه وما بين
الفينه والاخرى تحليق كثير في الطيران
الحربي هنالك حركه خروج من المدينه
شاهدناها في هذا الصباح
واصحاب المحاله التجاريه
باتجاه موقف
السفريات
الداخليه موقف الشندي اقصى شمال المدينه
باتجاه السفر ويبدو بان هذه الحركه انتظمت
في الايام الفائته واصبح هذا هو المخرج
والمسلك الان لعدد كبير جدا من سكان
المدينه الى اين تشد الرحال من الخرطوم
فيما يتعلق ببقيه الولايات في السودان
يعني هل من المناطق محدده يركز عليها
النازحون
يعني هنالك حديث يدور من خلال مشاهدات ومن
خلال استطلاعات عديده معهم بان الحديث
يدور بالذهاب الى مدينه شندي او الى مدينه
واد مدني بولايه الجزيره ربما تسير رحلات
الى هاتين المديتين ولكن هنالك ايضا حديث
عن المناطق اكثر امنا فيما يخص المناطق
الشماليه في مدينه بحري مناطق الكدر او
مناطق الدروشاب او الساموراب هذه المناطق
يعتبرها عدد من الاهالي هنا لانها اكثر
امنا من المناطق المتاخمه
لوسط الخرطوم والجسور التي تربط ما بين
مدينه بحري ومدينه الخرطوم طيب عمار ايضا
هناك انباعا ان المعارك بدات تنتقل من
دائره القياده العامه والمطار وسط الخرطوم
الى مناطق اخرى داخل العاصمه ايضا نتحدث
عن سلاح المدرعات مثلا وهيئه تصنيع الحربي
وبقيه المناطق في جنوب الخرطوم هل متاكده
حول ذلك
حتى الان يعني عدد من الاخبار التي رشحت
وعدد من المعلومات ان الاشتباكات ما زالت
تدور في محيط القياده العامه ولكن ربما
انحسرت هذه الاشتباكات لافعال كثيره جدا
او عسكريه كثيره جدا خاصه مع التعزيزات
العسكريه للقوات المسلحه التي انتظمت في
الفتره الاخيره وبحسب المعلومات الوارده
من ارض
المعركه الان بان ربما الكفه ترجح القوات
المسلحه بنسبه كبيره هذا لطبيعه العمليه
العسكريه في هذه المنطقه وايضا هذه القوات
قوات الدعم السريع لديها مرونه في الحركه
مما جعل او يسر لها عمليه تسيير عمليات
النوعيه في هذه المنطقه نعم في جنوب
الخرطوم هنالك اشتباكات سمعنا عنها كثيرا
في الايام الفائته ولكن في هذا الصباح
ايضا سمعنا عن اشتراكات في منطقه ام درمان
اعاده من جديد فيما يخص سلاح المهندسين
وفيما يخص ايضا المنطقه المجاوره لمباني
في زيون يعني نفهم انه بحسب مشاهدتك
ومتابعاتك يعني كفه الحسم العسكري
والسيطره على الارض تميل الى اي طرف من
الطرفين المتقاتلين الان يعني
حسب المعلومات وبحسب ما نراه من فيديوهات
وما ينشر من اخبار والمعلومات الوارده
الان يعني ترجح كافه القوات المسلحه بنسبه
ما ولكن عمليه وطبيعه قوات الدعم السريع
في المرور العسكريه في التحرك وهذا هو
طبيعه تكوين هذه القوات ربما سهل لها
وبالنسبه كبيره بان تحقق عمليات نوعيه في
سيطر تتحكم في منطقه ومن ثم تعود مره اخرى
وتنسحب ومن ثم تعود مره اخرى وتسيطر على
هذه المنطقه وايضا بان الجيش ربما يلعب
على عمليه الصبر الطويل والنفس الطويل
ولكن هذا ما يقول هذه المعركه الى
الاستمرار ربما لايام اخرى او ربما تطول
هذه المعركه وتذهب الى حرب شوارع وحرب مدن
مفتوحه اذا ما يعني في الحسبان بان هذه
القوات قوات الدعم السريع يعني هناك حديث
بان الامداد لم ينقطع منها ما زالت هنالك
مؤن موجوده داخل هذه القوات وما زالت
تسيطر على مواقع استراتيجيه في العاصمه
طيب فيما يتعلق بهذه السيطره التي اشرت
اليها يعني هناك حديث عن ارتكازات متعدده
لقوات الدعم السريع في مناطق مختلفه من
الخرطوم خاصه في منطقه شرق النيل منطقه
المبنى الاذاعه والتلفزيون ما طبيعه هذه
ارتكازات ما الذي يحدث فيها هل يتم فيها
التعرض للمواطنين ام التعامل معهم بشكل
سلمي باختصار لو سمحت عمر
يعني المواطن تحول الى مواطن صحفي ينشر
طياره بشكل واضح وشفاف عديد من المواطنين
تحدثوا عن هذه الارتكازات في عدد من
الشوارع خاصه منطقه شرق النيل والمناطق من
ام درمان القديمه تحدثوا عن ارتكازات
لقوات الدعم السريع لكن هنالك من يتحدث عن
ان هنالك عمليات سحب من هذه القوات وهناك
من يتحدث بانه لم يفعلوا لهم شيئا وربما
يسر لهم الحركه في عدد من المناطق
طيب شكرا لك على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل كنت معنا بالخرطوم بحري الصحفي
عمار ابو شريف تحياتي السيد عمار
يا لهوي
[تصفيق]
يا جماعه
الاشتباكات المسلحه مشاهدينا في السودان
بين الجيش والدعم الدعم السريع اسفرت عن
سقوط ضحايا من بينهم من يعمل في القطاع
الطبي والصحي كطبيبتين نجوى خالد حمد
والاء فوز المرضي اللتين قتلت برصاصات
طائشه
خلال الازمات والحروب يكون الاطباء في
الصف الامامي لتقديم المساعده للمصابين
وانقاذهم وفي حالات اخرى يكون هؤلاء
الاطباء في مرمى نيران المواجهات المسلحه
في السودان الامر لا يختلف اطباء راحوا
ضحايا للاقتتال المستمر الطبيبه نجوى خالد
حمد اصيبت بطلق ناري اثناء عودتها للمنزل
ما ادى لوفاتها الى جانب الطبيبه الاء
فوزي المرضي التي قتلت اثرار رصاصه طائشه
والصيدلي ابو ذر محمد زين الذي اردته
نيران الاشتباكات المسلحه قتيلا
[موسيقى]
تيجاني مسلتي كان احد ابرز جنود احتجاجات
ديسمبر قاد المظاهرات التي اندلعت في
السودان اواخر العام 2018 قدم خدمات
علاجيه للمحتاجين وشارك في العديد من
الانشطه الميدانيه والاغاثيه لم يكن يعلم
انه سيكون ضحيه الاشتباكه الجاريه في
السودان قتل بعد ان سقطت عليه قذيفه في
مكان اقامته جراء الاقتتال الدائر بين
الجيش والدعم السريع نعاه زملائه في العمل
الطوعي ووصفوه باحد الجنود المجهولين
بثوره ديسونج مشاهدينا من الخرطوم نعود د
مره اخرى الى ضيفنا السيد عادل السيد احمد
الكاتب الصحفي المعنى من جديد في هذه
التغطيه
بعيدا عن الجانب العسكري لهذه الازمه
هل تعتقد ان الالواقعه الحالي يفرض ربما
على النخب السياسيه في السودان اعاده
النظر في وضع المكونات السياسيه وربما
تغيير ايضا منهج التفكير القائم في
العقليه السياسيه السودانيه وبالتالي ربما
نتحدث عن خلق عمليه سياسيه جديده برؤى
وبمفاهيم جديده
بالطبع انا اعتقد انه
في اخر مفاوضات وهي مفاوضات الاتفاق
الايطالي
توضحت افكار
ما جاوبت او اجابت على كل الاسئله المهمه
والملحه في الازمه السياسيه في السودان
والتي ظهرت مستمره
ولكن كان ينقص هذه الاطروحه التي قامت على
ورش والتي قامت على نهج علمي ينقصها ان
كل القوه السياسيه السودانيه واعتقد انه
هذه
عله التنافس السياسي بين القوى السياسيه
ظلت هذه العله موجوده من بعد
1956 وحتى الان من المهم جدا ان يتم تدارك
هذه العله وايجاد حلول لها لانك الان
تتحدث عن بلد قبل الحرب كان مازوما فما
بالك بعد الحرب انا اعتقد انه مطلوب من
القوى السياسيه ان ترتقي لمستوى معاناه
شعب السودان والتي كانت متفاقمه قبل قبل
الحرب وتضاعفت الان بشكل اكبر بعض الحرب
وستبين نتائج هذا التدهور بشكل واضح بعد
ان ان يتوقف صوت الرصاص مطلوب من القوات
السياسيه في هذه الظروف ان تقوم بمراجعات
اساسيه ومراجعات كبيره كي تخرج من نطاق
التنافس السياسي والفكري الضيق الى رحاب
تحقيق انجازات حقيقيه من اجل المواطن
السوداني والذي هو الذي المواطن السوداني
هو الذي هذه الثوره وهو الذي اسقط النظام
البشير النخب السياسيه كانت موجوده وكان
لها دور وليس في ذلك شك ولكن للشعب
السوداني هو الذي قرر اسقاط وانهاء نظام
البشير على كل النخب السياسيه ان تعيد
النظر في طريقه التفكير الضيق وان ان تجلس
او طبعا ده بعد ما تتوقف هذه الحرب
اللعينه ان تجلس الاطراف وتقوم بمراجعات
حقيقيه ومراجعات اساسيه كي تتجه الى خطوه
جديده تقوم على مدنيه الدوله وبناء
السودان الجديد على اساس ديمقراطي وعلى
اساس مدني نعم
جزيلا لك من الخطوط معنا عادل السيد احمد
الكاتب الصحفي تحيه استاذ عادل
مخاوف انهيار للوضع الصحي مشاهدينا بشكل
كامل ليس المشكله الوحيده الان هناك ازمه
مياه في الخرطوم تتفاقم ايضا بعد مرور
اكثر من خمسه ايام على انقطاعها بالكامل
عن معظم المناطق السكنيه في العاصمه حيث
يعيش السودانيون في ظروف صعبه بسبب انقطاع
المياه والكهرباء معا وما زاد من معاانتهم
ايضا نقصد غذائه وشح الخدمات الاساسيه في
ظل استمرار الاشتباكات
المهندسين
كثير جدا من الاحياء والمربعات المجاوره
رجل لنفس الاتجاه والمنطقه بقت منطقه
الناس بيكونوا موجودين فيها وبياخدوا منها
المياه الجوفيه وهي المياه برضو مش صالحه
للشرب غدر ما هي ممكن يتم استخدامك اشياء
ثانيه
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على مائده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نزمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل خمسه عشر
مليون شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات
الغذاء الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين
طفل دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء
التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا الحقت اضرارا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم
عائلات اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه
واحده فقط في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع
الظروف الصعبه الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص
سكانها فرصه هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى
محلات البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما
خاصه التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
اغلب الاحتياجات من نقدر نجيبه بالنسبه
لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقفه مساعداته للبلاد على وقع
مقتل ثلاثه من موظفيه نتيجه الاشتباكات
بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
مشاهدينا نشير الى هذا الخبر العاجل
القوات الدعم السريع تستخدمه المضادات
الارضيه اذا في هذه الصور المتداوله الان
تستخدم المضادات الارضيه ضد مقاتلات الجيش
فوق العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم مشاهدينا
اذا هذه الصور المتداوله لقوات الدعم
السريع وهي تستخدم
المضادات الارضيه على بطن هذه السيارات
رباعيه الدفع ضد المقاتلات الحربيه
السودانيه فوق العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم
ذلك طبعا ياتي في سياق المعارك الدائره
لليوم السادس على دوالي في الخرطوم ومناطق
مختلفه من السودان وسط سيطره يعلن عنها
الطرفان
دون اي تاكيدات لحسم عسكري واضح وهناك
ايضا الحديث ايضا يجري عن فشل الهدنه التي
اوضحت
المؤشرات وشهد العيان ومراسلين الذين
صدفناهم ان هذه الهدنه لم تنجح اليوم بسبب
الاشتباكات التي لم تتوقف وان كانت قد خفت
وترتها قليلا في الساعات الماضيه مقارنه
بالايام الماضيه المشاهدين هذه صور
متداوله
للقوات الدعم السريع وهي تستخدم هذه
المضادات الارضيه المحاوله او كمحاوله
تصدي للمقاتلات الحربيه التابعه لقوات
الجيش السوداني
من جنوب الخرطوم مشاهدينا ينضم الينا
الصحفي مدثر
من جديد وبدايه هناك بعض الانباء
المتداوله عن انتقال دائره المعارك من
منطقه وسط الخرطوم الى مناطق اخرى ايضا في
السودان بما فيها او مناطق اخرى في
الخرطوم فيها جنوب العاصمه الخرطوم حيث
تتواجد حيث يمكن ان تؤكد لنا هذه
المعلومات او تنفيذها
[موسيقى]
نرى لازمنا نرى اعمده الدخان تتصاعد من
تلك المنطقه منطقه تلك الاشتباكات ولكن
الان منذ حوالي الساعه او ساعه ونصف لم
نسمع لاي اصوات للاشتباكات في هذه المنطقه
وفي المنطقه الجنوب الخرطوم عدد منذ
ساعتين تقريبا حركه حركه العاديه في الش
وارع تتجه من الخرطوم الى خارج الى خارج
الولايه الطريقه القومي الرابط بين
الخرطوم وولايات ولايات السودان الاخرى
عادت اليه الحركه الطبيعيه خلال الساعه او
ساعتين الماضيتين
هناك حركه سفر متواصله منذ صباح هذا اليوم
ربما هي احدى
احدى احدى الاستثمارات التي استثمرها من
المواطنون خلال الهدنه التي بدات منذ
الامس الهدنه بحسب المراقبين لم لم لم لم
يكن هناك بها التزام كامل شهدت ساعات
الصباح الاولى كما تابعتم
اشتراكات عديده في عدد من مناطق ولاه
الخرطوم في وسط الخرطوم في ام درمان وفي
شرقه
وكذلك في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم كانت هناك
اشتباكات في عظم من المناطق لم نتاكد حتى
الان يعني كل طرف
هو الذي بدا بدا الخلق الهدنه ولكن
الى بعض الذين بعض الاصحاب اصحاب المركبات
التي الذين ينقلون المساكنين الى خارج
الولايه
من الخرطومات تحدث عن انه لا يوجد هناك اي
عوائق او ارتكازات امنيه تعيق حركه
المسافرين تحدث عن انه بالامس قام بعدد من
الرحلات بين الخرطوم وولاده الجزيره
وولايه ان هناك طريق كان امنا
فتره الصباحيه قال ان بعض البعض تحدثنا في
الفتره الم كانت هناك بعض
المعيقات التي من خلال بعض الارتكازات في
بعض الطرق كانت ليست هناك درجه من الامان
كافيه ولكن فتره الصباحيه قال انه لا احد
يوقف تلك العربات تلك المركبات المتجهه من
الخرطوم الى خارج البلاد نعم نحن الان انا
اتحدث
ان الخرطوم
من الناحيه من الناحيه الشرقيه او الطريقه
الذي يذهب الى ولايه الجزيره
نتمنى لك السلامه بالتاكيد ولجميع
المواطنين ساكتفي بهذا القدر بدق الوقت
شكرا لك من جنوب الخرطوم كنت معنا الصحفي
مده محمد احمد مشاهدينا نتابع ايضا معكم
هذه الصور ايضا التي هي صور متداوله ايضا
لقوات الجيش التي سيطرت على سيارات
ومدرعات ومركبات الدفع الرباعي لقوات
الدعم السريع في ولايه القضارف فاذا هذه
الصور
لقوات الجيش التي سيطرت على هذه السيارات
التي كانت مملوكه لقوات الدعم السريع وهي
سياره دفع رباعي تبدو فيها الاسلحه وبعد
العضلات ايضا قد سيطرت عليها قوات الجيش
في منطقه القضارف
والمشاهد مشاهدين ايضا هذه
سريع الصور ايضا كما تبدو وفيها فرحه
هؤلاء الجنود
بالسيطره على هذه السيارات وعلامات النصر
وكل ذلك مشاهدين ايضا ياتي في سياق هذه
المعارك المستعره منذ سته ايام في مناطقها
مختلفه من السودان
باصوات القذائف منذ الصباح وتبادل اطلاق
النار وقاحه الرصاص سمعت في المرافق
مختلفه وخاصه الخرطوم في مقر الجيش والقصر
الجمهوري ومبنى تلفزيون والسلاح المهندسين
رغم هذه الهدنه التي لم تصمد امام عدوي
الرصاص
ايضا مشاهدينا استهدفون العميد في الجيش
السوداني عبد العظيم احمد بالعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم وخلال تشجيع جنازته
تحلق حول جثمانه ابنائه وزوجته
السالب القتال تختلف ووسائله تتعدد
في السودان كما في اي منطقه توتر كل شيء
مباح لهزم الطرف الاخر
قناصه متخفون استهدفوا العميد عبد العظيم
احمد بالقرب من سلاح الاشاره بالعاصمه
الخرطوم
خلال تشييع جنازته تحلق حوله ابناءه
وزوجته مودعين اياه الى مثواه الاخير قبيل
ايام قليله فقط من عيد الفطر
[موسيقى]
كانوا يلعبون امام منازلهم لكن قذيفه غدرت
بهم مقاتلتهم في عمر الزهور ثلاثه اطفال
سودانيين شقيقان وابن خالتهما راحوا ضحيه
الاشتباكات المسلحه في العاصمه السودانيه
الخرطوم نتابع
اسلحه القتال لا تفرق بين الرجال والنساء
ولا حتى بين الكبار والصغار تحصد ارواح كل
من تجد في طريقها محمد بابكر ومعتز بابكر
وابن خالتهما منذر عوض ثلاثه اطفال كانوا
مشغولين باللعب تحت شجره قرب منزلهم في
منطقه الجريف بالعاصمه السودانيه
قبل ان تسقط عليهم قذيفه وتنهي حياتهم
فورا جراء الاشتباكات المتواصله بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
بدت شوارع مدينه بورسودان شمال شرق البلاد
خاليه الا من بعض الاشخاص الذين حملوا
امتعتهم وفروا من القتال الدائر بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في العاصمه الخرطوم حيث
افاد شهود عيان بوجود جثث في شوارع
العاصمه
تغطيهنا مستمره مشاهدينا الزميله راويه
العالمي تصحبكم على ارض السعه متابعتهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات